6 24 on your wednesday morning got our
periodic junior traffic buddy lesson in
reporting traffic signal issues viewer
shari writes hey during afternoon rush
hour traffic backs up onto the westbound
southern 250 beltway the exit to durango
and sunset and she says it causes a very
dangerous situation well i suggest that
you and anyone who has ever sent in
intersection specific emails about
signals visit the regional
transportation commission's website it's
called seeing orange nv seeing orange
nv.com they've got email addresses and a
phone number where your call will be
answered by a real person between the
hours of 5 a.m to 11 p.m monday through
friday 7am to 8pm weekend uh the number
702-901-8400 you'll have to write that
down right now it is in the online
version of this and all of our stories
on our eight news now.com website click
traffic then driving you crazy and
thanks for writing in buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone you
want to write in the email address
traffic eight eight news now dot com